really none of this concerns you
Jake Tapper Democrat activist Jake
Tapper over on CNN had Secretary of
State Anthony blinken on his show over
the weekend and they were talking about
how Elon Musk is not letting the U.S
government do whatever it wants whenever
it wants whether Elon should be punished
SpaceX CEO Elon Musk has recently
confirmed a report that's in Walter
isaacson's new biography of mosque that
last year musk blocked access to his
Starling satellite Network in Crimea in
order to disrupt the major Ukrainian
attack on the Russian Navy there in
other words
musk effectively sabotaged a military
operation by Ukraine a U.S Ally against
Russia an aggressor country that invaded
a U.S Ally should there be repercussions
for that
Jake I can't speak to a specific episode
here's what I can tell you
starlink has been a vital tool for the
ukrainians to be able to communicate
with each other and particularly for the
military to communicate in their effort
to defend all of Ukraine's territory it
remains so and I would expect it to to
continue to be critical to their efforts
so what we would uh hope and expect is
that that technology will remain fully
available to the ukrainians it is vital
to what they're doing
I don't know that you can't speak to it
you won't speak to it are you concerned
that musk is apparently conducting his
own diplomatic Outreach to the Russian
government really none of this concerns
you
Jake I can't speak to conversations that
may or may not have happened I don't
know
um I'm focused on the fact that the
technology itself starlink has been
really important to ukrainians it
remains so sounds like starling's so
important the US government doesn't want
to risk offending a capricious
billionaire who did some things that I
think in another situation the US
government might want to say something
about but let's move all right there's
two things that I really want to point
out on this regardless of how any of us
feel about the war whether Elon Musk
should help or shouldn't help what is
what are your rights as a private
citizen even though if you have
government contracts or you get
subsidies Etc to have the government or
in this case the army use your
technology let's put some of that stuff
aside for a second the two points really
first off Jake says that uh that Elon
Musk had diplomatic Outreach to the
Russian government as far as we can find
there is no evidence of that that Elon
Musk reached out to the Russians
regarding any of this he pulled back
starlink's ability from the U.S
government in this case because he
didn't want to instigate he didn't want
to help instigate a military attack that
could blow up the whole damn thing but
as far as we could tell there is
literally no evidence of that if any of
you were watching and you can prove me
wrong on that or correct us or clarify
that please do let me know the other
line though that I think is the scary
line really gets to the heart of it Jake
Tapper says should there be
repercussions now again it doesn't
matter what you think whether Elon Musk
should allow this technology to be used
or not but the idea that a journalist is
asking the Secretary of State basically
should we take out should we imprison
should we find this private citizen
because he's not helping you ramp up the
war the non-declared war effort just
because you want to he has different
feelings about it and he didn't want to
as I said instigate World War III uh
this seems like a bit of a problem right
like is Jake Tapper a agent hint of the
machine or is he a journalist well I
think you know your answer